Maddi you've changed a lot since you
first appeared on Dance Moms and well
that's to be expected you were like nine
years old after all but we never once
thought that you'd stop hanging out with
your friends from the ALDC we get it
you're a big star and all but what about
your old pal Kendall vertes you girls
used to be attached by the hip and now
we hardly ever see you guys together
anymore so what's going on Maddie we
want some answers I don't really think I
have anything to say about her yeah if
you're like us you probably thought that
Maddie and Kendall's friendship was
goals but now you're not so sure what
happened between these two stars and
could fame really be what got in their
way that's what we're trying to figure
out watch until the end to find out why
Maddie stardom drastically changed her
friendship with Kendall growing up on
the set of Dance Moms isn't an easy
thing to do which is why having a bestie
to lean on is a must
Maddie and Kendall became fast friends
in season two of Dance Moms
in fact the girls were so close that
they quickly labeled themselves as the
bros it said that maddie is responsible
for getting Kendall on The Dance Moms
squad she supposedly told Abby Lee
Miller to choose Kendall while
off-screen the girls were best of
friends for years but for some strange
reason we hardly ever see them together
anymore it's been years since Maddie and
Kendall have appeared on Dance Moms
Maddie left in 2016 at the end of season
6 I want to end on a high note and make
this the best two ette we've ever done
while Kendall stayed on for another
season seeing a part of the Dance Moms
squad is super demanding which basically
put a damper on Kendall and Maddie's
friendship to top it all off Kendall was
still at the ALDC while Maddie was
becoming a huge star thanks to her
mentor SIA I mean she has changed my
life freely Kendall and Maddie did their
best to keep in touch but hectic
schedules got in their way
in April of 2019 Kendall had a family
reunion with Maddie and Nia and the
girls seemed to be getting along just
fine when you look at their Instagram
accounts they hardly ever post pictures
of each other anymore which is sort of a
red flag considering how OnPoint their
social media games are Dance Moms fans
couldn't believe how quickly things
changed but
Maddie and Kendall but once Maddie left
ALDC Kendall and Kalani quickly became
best friends and formed the
irreplaceable alongside Chloe it's our
first official week as it replaceable
something must have gone on between the
bros and this was basically confirmed
when Maddie didn't wish Kendall a happy
birthday in 2018
oddly enough months before her own
birthday Kendall posted a heartfelt
birthday shout out for Maddie on her
Instagram page so something must have
happened between October and December of
2018 for Maddie Mackenzie and their
mother Melissa to not wish Kendall a
happy birthday at all we can blame it on
their hectic schedules I don't know I
want to do it all but something tells us
there's more to the story than what we
see on social media if there's one thing
we couldn't help but notice it's that
Kendall vertes isn't opposed to seeing
Abby Lee Miller
Kendall posted a picture of her former
dance coach back in January of 2019
Kendall went on to comment that Abby was
the strongest woman she knew and that
she loved her although both Maddie and
Kendall didn't visit Abby while she was
in the hospital and starting
chemotherapy Kendall isn't giving her
the silent treatment it's possible that
Maddie and Kendall didn't see eye-to-eye
on this subject and since Maddie has
made it abundantly clear that she has no
interest in burying the hatchet with
Abby Lee Miller I don't really think I
have anything to say about her yeah this
might have caused a rift between the old
besties whether Abby Lee Miller got in
between the girls friendship is up for
debate but there's one clear factor at
play when we look at their fizzled out
friendship both Kendall and Maddie are
extremely busy
Kendall kept busy with the irreplaceable
then went on to star in a movie titled
Rapunzel of princess frozen in time on
top of that Kendall's been working on
releasing some singles while going to
school she's also in the process of
filming movies like Santa and training
in anesthesia so it goes without saying
but she has little time to socialize but
add fuel to the fire Maddy is even
busier on top of touring with SIA and
collaborating with brands like fabletics
and pop-tarts I love my pop-tarts trick
me foil but I want to see how you eat
yours Maddy is also in the process of
filming West Side Story on top of that
the girls aren't even living in the same
States which makes meeting up for a
nightcap
pretty much impossible although every
single Dance Moms Oh G has made a name
for themselves
Maddy is the most famous of them all and
well with a lot of theme comes a new
entourage Maddy quickly started hanging
out with a different pool of people and
so did Kendall according to insider
Maddy his best friends with stranger
things start Millie Bobby Brown I mean I
definitely look up to her as an actress
whereas Kendall is a lot closer to
Kalani thank you everybody
Maddie's extreme Fame definitely put a
halt to her friendship with Kendall but
what was she supposed to do stop
pursuing her career on top of that
Maddie has also been keeping busy with
her alleged boyfriend kale and Morris
who's the son of the legendary Stevie
Wonder despite their mature facade
Maddie and Kendall are still young
teenagers and they're just trying to
figure everything out they're busy with
schoolwork boys and everything in
between so it's perfectly normal that
the bros are doing their own things
the girls have hung out since Maddie
brushed off Kendall's birthday so they
definitely aren't enemies
it looks like the childhood besties have
moved on to new people we're all so
close and I love them so much but that
doesn't mean that they don't love each
other from afar why do you guys think
Kendall and Maddie aren't best friends
anymore did they get into a fight or did
Maddie's career get in the way
sound off in the comments section below
and that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up if you love Dance Moms and be
sure to subscribe to the thing so you
never miss another video thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]